معنا من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل الغول نقف معك اسماعيل
على اخر التطورات خلال هذه
الساعه نعم في الساعات الاخيره او في
اللحظات الاخيره اطلقت طائره كوات كابتر
في محيط مستشفى الشفاء العديد من الطلقات
الناريه مما ادى الى استشهاد مواطن في
المناطق الغربيه لمستشفى الشفاء بالاضافه
الى اصابه الطابق الرابع من مستشفى
الولاده ببعض الطلقات دون وقوع اصابات رغم
على الرغم من الاصابه المباشره في داخل
مستشفى الشفاء بالاضافه الى مرور الطلقات
الناريه من فوق اسطح مستشفى الشفاء هذه
الاسطح او هذه الطلقات يسمع دويها وصفير
خلال مرورها من اعلى مستشفى الشفاء يبدو
ان قوات الاحتلال تستمر في اطلاق النار وا
اطلاق القذائف في هذا في المناطق الغربيه
بالتحديد اما عن المناطق الغربيه الشماليه
منطقه حي الشيخ رضوان تستمر ايضا طائرات
الكوات كابتر باطلاق النار على كل من
يقترب من منطقه بهل لول واطراف منطقه حي
النصر الاطراف الشماليه من منطقه حي النصر
الواقعه شمال مدينه غزه بالاضافه الى
اطلاق القذائف الصاروخيه وقذائف المدفعيه
وقذائف
وصواريخ الطائرات المسيره على كل من يتحرك
في هذه المناطق هي التي تعتبر على تماس
واضح مع قوات الاحتلال لكن الكثير من
المواطنين يصرون على التوجه الى منازلهم
واقتياد بعد ما تبقى من طعام او ملابس او
غطاء في ظل حركه النزوح الكبيره التي كانت
قبل ايام دون
وخروجهم من منازلهم دون ادنى مقومات
الحياه حتى اغطيه او ملابس لم تخرج هذه
العائلات لكن يبدو ان العائلات كانت تحاول
وقصفت عدد من المواطنون في تلك المناطق
ووصل العديد من الاصابات الى مستشفى
الشفاء على مدار الايام السابقه بعد
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال اما عن المناطق
الشرقيه فوفق مصادر من المواطنين وصلوا
الى اطراف المناطق الشرقيه من منطقه حي
التفاح وحي الشجاعيه وشرق حي الزيتون هذه
المناطق التي كانت تتواجد قوات الاحتلال
قبل ايام ايضا بها لكن انسحبت بشكل كامل
اما بالانتقال الى شمال قطاع غزه فمنطقه
بيت حانون واطراف تل الزعتر ومنطقه جباليا
وجباليا البلد واطراف منطقه بيت لاهيه كل
هذه المناطق اصبحت بلا احتلال وبلا قوات
اسرائيليه قوات الاحتلال انسحبت من هذه
المناطق وتنفذ قصف ما بين المدنيين او
تجمعات المواطنين في هذه المناطق اما عن
الحاله الانسانيه لازالت صعبه بالتحديد
داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي والطواقم الطبيه
تحاول وتكرر مساعيها في اعاده تشغيل غرف
مزيد من غرف العمليه بعد ايام من تشغيلها
داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي لانقاذ حياه
المرضى وهناك نداءات من بنك الدم بالتوجه
للتبرع بالدم بالتحديد فصيله او سالب
لانقاذ حياه المصابين والمرضى مرضى
التلاسيميا بالتحديد ومرضى الكلى الذين هم
بحاجه دائمه الى مزيد من الوحدات الدم
التي تنقذ حياتهم من الموت اسماعيل ايضا
دعنا نرحب بزميل مؤمن الشرافي انضم الينا
من خان يونس مراسل الجزيره وننوه ايضا الى
ان هنالك قصفا بحسب مراسله الجزيره في
مناطق مختلفه بشمال قطاع غزه وهنالك دوي
انفجارات تسمع بين الحين والاخر وهذا يطرح
سؤالا حول المرحله التي يعيشها شمال غزه
الان في ضوء اعلان اعلام اسرائيلي نقل عن
وزير الدفاع ان المرحله الثالثه في شمال
غزه قد بدات بالفعل نريد ان ترصد لنا
ملامح هذه المرحله الثالثه في شمال قطاع
غزه وفق ما نسمعه كل لحظه عن انفجارات هنا
وهناك وعن قصف هنا
وهناك نعم كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن
مراحل مختلفه في شمال قطاع غزه بالتحديد
في منطقه مدينه غزه وشمال قطاع غزه هذهه
المناطق التي عايشت احتلال اسرائيل لكن
يبدو ان مراحل المرحله الثالثه هي مرحله
انسحاب قوه الاحتلال من كافه المحاور
انسحبت من من ما يقارب 70% من مناطق شمال
قطاع غزه وبقيت هي المناطق من او ما يزيد
عن 40% سحبت من 60% من مناطق شمال قطاع
غزه وبقي ما يقارب 40% هي تحت وطاه احتلال
الجيش الاسرائيلي وحتى هذه اللحظه قوات
الاحتلال تنفذ اغتيالات او قصف مباشر
لتجمعات المواطنين وهي المرحله التي تحدث
عنها جيش الاحتلال لكن غالبيه هذا القصف
يقع بحق المدنيين فقبل ايام قصفت قوات
الاحتلال تجمع للمواطنين قرب مفترق
السرايا واليوم قصفت تجمع للمواطنين قرب
منطقه دوار حيدر وهذه المناطق او استهدفت
تجمع للمواطنين وبالامس استه هدفت مبنى
سكني او بنايه سكنيه مرتفعه في منطقه مخيم
الشاطئ مما ادى الى استشهاد ثلاث
فلسطينيين يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال تنفذ
عمليه قصف عشوائي بالاضافه الى قصف مركز
كما يدعي جيش الاحتلال بانها استهداف
لقيادات حماس لكن وفق المصادر الميدانيه
انه لا يوجد اي استهداف لقياده من قيادات
المقاومه في شمال قطاع غزه خلال الايام
الاخيره